joining me now is Glenn yunan governor
of Virginia governor first
congratulations um you're a business guy
you understand what motivates business
um but second what was the driving
factor to your understanding behind Ted
Leon's
move well Laura first of all thanks for
having me and it's been an exciting day
in Virginia you know this announcement
that we are going to form a public
private partnership like done in America
where Monumental Sports in the city of
Alexandria and of course the
Commonwealth of Virginia are going to
bring together all of our capabilities
to develop A2 billion sports and
entertainment District that will be the
home to two great teams the Washington
Wizards and the Washington Capitals
we're also going to see the Monumental
headquarters move to Virginia with 600
jobs we're going to develop a 6,000 seat
concert venue uh a Convention Center
hotels mixed use restaurants and of
course Housing and Community space so
it's very exciting it also is going to
generate 12 billion of economic impact
over the next several decades and 30,000
jobs and it will be I think the most
creative financing structure because of
the fact that we're not putting up an
upfront upfront payment I told Virginia
taxpayers I do a good deal for Virginia
and I think we've negotiated a chance
for all three Partners to win together
where we in fact will generate
substantial tax r revenues over time and
use those tax revenues to finance this
$2 billion project along with a $400
million investment for Monumental Sports
it's really exting it's a big day theth
and fun to do don't start talking like a
finance guy on the Ingram angle okay I
mean I know that's your background no
I'm just teasing you um but crime I know
tedly owns this over the years crime was
part of this decision crime was part of
this decision Governor um without a
doubt I was in DC when the Verizon
Center I think it was called the verison
center then was built and I saw how that
area of DC was totally revitalized you
probably remember that in the early '
80s DC and that area was a disaster it
came to life with investment and so
forth crime has been a major problem in
the city really since before covid uh
and Co made it all worse that had to be
part of this decision as well nobody
wants to go
downtown well of course as you
highlighted Across America we've got a
huge divide we've got winners and losers
and and we see it in states where the
states that are led by Republican
Governors are winning and the states
that are led by Democrat Governors are
losing and the data is just so clear and
when I came into to this position and
and Virginia hired me I knew that we had
to do a number of things one we have to
get the cost of living down second we've
got to increase the education quality
third we have to make our community safe
and fourth we have to have a government
that works for people and doesn't tell
them what to do all the time and this is
translated into an an economic
revitalization for the Commonwealth we
have 230,000 more people working today
than when we started just two years ago
we went from the bottom of job growth to
number three in the nation and job
growth during this time Peri govern this
is reflective but it would have been
nice if this came out before the
election right for the State House
elections it probably would have it
wouldn't have hurt that's for sure
correct I mean you you you it wasn't as
bad as people said it was in Virginia
for Republicans but it also wasn't what
you or certainly I as a proud Virginia
resident um want uh wanted we wanted the
Republicans to take the house in the
Senate they did not um but given that
how do you in the next few years how do
you continue to show the people of this
you know incredible State why this works
why Common Sense policies work and why
these cities are
collapsing well of course I I was
disappointed with the outcome of the
elections the the redistricting was an
uphill battle we knew it and really we
look back at this and there's about
11,000 votes that if they had gone the
other direction uh we would have we
would have held both houses and and
that's just that's the reality we had
split government going into this and
we'll have split government coming out
of it nothing happens without without
both houses passing a bill and a
governor signing it and so we'll find
lots of good things to work on together
and I do believe Laura that Common Sense
conservative policies continue to
demonstrate that they are effective you
cannot argue with the success numbers in
Virginia relative to when we got there
just two years ago and most importantly
we're going to continue to drive forward
with the same policies and this is a
chance for us to come together and
really deliver for Virginia this this
announcement this morning I think
reflects that it reflects the fact that
companies want to be in Virginia I mean
we've had Boeing and rathon and Lego and
Hilton Double Down in Virginia we we
we've had people move to Virginia who
are moving away we've had people stay
who are moving away common sense
conservative policies work the the
winning states are the states that have
the formula the losing states are the
ones that don't and uh and I think that
Americans are seeing this across the
country and that's why they're all
moving to the states that have
Republican leadership well it's time
that uh the cities wake up I mean if
they keep voting for the same people and
the same policies they're going to get
the same results it's really sad for me
to see as a longtime DC resident uh
what's happening there but Governor
congratulations you got it done I look
forward to seeing how it all plays out
thank you so much
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere
else